- So you're a grandpa as well.
And you posted this
video of your grandson.
So let's see.
- Look who's on the TV?
Who's that? Look! Look!
- Grand dude! Grand dude!
Grand dude! Grand dude!
- Aw, what was goin' on
there? He recognized you?
- That's little Sam.
I don't know if it was the
first time he recognized me,
but that was the first time
I actually finally heard him
say grand dude.
Which I've been working on.
- Oh.
- Did he say "Grand Dude"?
- Grand Dude. That's what he...
I know it sounds like grand nude.
I love that he's saying grand dude.
Yeah, and I remember the
day I had done a broadcast
and it wasn't a great broadcast.
I was feeling, you know,
eh, and then I get this text
from my daughter-in-law with
that video and I just melt.
That's the thing about kids,
- Oh, I get it.
it takes you out of everything
else going on in your life.
Perspective is crazy.
So I've been working
on grand dude with him,
when my daughter-in-law was
pregnant with her first baby
she said, "Well, What do
you guys want to be called?"
And I said, I think I wanna be grand dude
because it granted, it bows
to the fact that I'm older,
but dude says I still got a little.
- But I'm cool. I'm the cool grandad.
- So I've been working on
it and it's hard to say.
So that was so great,
Yes! he said it,
even though it came out of
grand nude, he gets credit.